let's have a look a little bit more
detail now about the situation on the
ground uh in ukraine and the strategy
that uh russia uh appears to be using
now i'm joined once again by defense and
security analyst professor michael clark
michael great to see you as always so
let's touch just first of all on the
strategy that russia is trying to now
put in place as it's moved troops to the
east and the south and and again
continues to focus on mario paul yes
as the map points out the russians are
trying to build a big force in the south
they've taken the issue and they're
trying to push down from israel towards
mariopol and mariopol's importance is
amongst other things is because it's the
southern anchor of this big push north
from mariopol south from israel to join
up their forces it will take some time
to do
but if they can if they can defeat the
ukrainians in mariopol they can release
probably half the force they've got
there at least six thousand maybe eight
thousand troops to then start to push
north in this big offensive that is
building up does mario pole look
increasingly likely to fall yes it does
uh most people think it's down to hours
now not days um we can see that the uh
the the ukrainian forces are now in two
pockets uh pushed up against the sea
they their last redoubt maybe the azov
style steel works they seem to retaken
bits of that but the marines reportedly
are now out of ammunition the russians
are saying that over a thousand have
surrendered that's not been contradicted
by the ukrainians and so i think
now
you can tell when front crack i think
the crack has occurred
and i'd be surprised if mario paul is
not in russian hands by this time
tomorrow and all of this is going on you
know with various troop movements
happening over the course of us we've
got some fresh pictures i think of of
some of these troop movements that that
have been witnessing uh over the last
day or so yeah i mean the the as of
style steel works i mean bigger steel
works in europe you can see why it's
such a fortress you can see why it
becomes the alamo for the final elements
of the of the marines uh the 36th marine
infantry who look as if they've had to
give up uh on that now and and mario
paul has been devastated i mean there is
nothing left of it as a city it was a
city of half a million people almost
half a million people now we don't know
how many civilians are still there
probably about a hundred thousand if
however many of them are alive and about
4 000 ukrainians have defended it for 46
47 days i wanted to ask michael as well
about the importance of morale in all of
this because i guess most of the last
week or so has been talk of morale of
the russian troops probably uh being low
if they're now successful in seizing
mario paul in other places maybe the
morale will shift in the opposite
direction how big a factor is morale in
these battles well it's a huge factor i
mean morale is is the hidden element in
any battle between two groups of forces
and although it is a big blow to the
ukrainians to lose mario paul
nevertheless it has been such an epic of
this war from day one until probably
tomorrow
um that i think that the cry will be
remember mario paul as they fight south
of israel around slavic uh slavians and
in those in those pockets
and and then just finally as well wanted
to to touch on this topic of phosphorus
bombs we touched on it a little bit
yesterday as well possibility of
chemical weapons being used if the west
were to prove that which is
still a long way off and wanted to up
their military assistance in response
are there lots of options of better
weapons that could be given that haven't
been given yet that would also mean they
don't have to enter the fray themselves
yes
a lot of weapons the west has has held
off giving because they think it would
be a bit escalatory but undoubtedly the
ukrainians need more tanks they need
more armored vehicles they still could
do with more aircraft whether mig-29s is
the right aircraft is a different issue
and more anti-aircraft but uh facilities
so i think there's quite a lot more if
the west was sufficiently outraged by
another threshold being crossed say due
to chemical weapons then i think more
lethal weaponry long-range weaponry
might well be given to the ukrainians
the problem would be not giving it to
them but getting it there in one piece
so that they could use it mike i might
get your reaction to this a little bit
of breaking news that's just crossing
the uk has said that it's added 206 new
listings uh under the russian sanctions
uh regime we need to get some more uh
details of that but but i guess you know
michael this isn't saying that we're
absolutely not importing any oil or gas
from russia immediately uh nor is it
saying sending some of the weapons that
you just mentioned but it shows the uk
continuing to increase the pressure week
by week day by day yes there's more
sanctions that could be taken if we're
prepared to hurt ourselves now sanctions
have got to the point where they will
start to hurt if we care enough then
we'll start to impose those sanctions
we'll ratchet it up we'll take the pain
and it will actually cause some quite
great distress i think to putin's
leadership michael as always thanks so
much
you